the live and Alive tour is off and
running St Louis I will see you on
August 4th and 5th La local show here
August 11th Tampa Florida August 18th
and 19th with Steve Simone Springfield
Missouri September 1st and 2nd Tulsa
Oklahoma September 15th and 16th Phoenix
Arizona September 29th and 30th Salt
Lake City I'll see you all October 27th
and the 28th in San Francisco California
I'm coming back December 8th and 9th get
your tickets to all shows at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan siglorn all your social
media and I want to say thank you thank
you whether you've been here whether
you're new here thank you for supporting
this show I genuinely love what I do for
a living make sure you subscribe to the
YouTube channel make sure you're sharing
the special Lefty son and if you got to
have more then you gotta check out the
patreon I am telling you
those stories it's called the Honeydew
with y'all I do this show with y'all and
y'all just decided not to be Comedians
and your stories are unlike anything
you're going to hear I don't care
Dateline can't hold a candle to it none
of them the stories are insane it's five
bucks a month if you or someone out
there has a story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com hopefully we get to do an
episode together all right and if you're
looking for a new podcast to listen to
check out my old podcast the crab Feast
I am telling you everybody in podcast
land Theo Vaughn Tom segora Bert
Kreischer Bill Burr Christina P
everybody has done that podcast uh go
check it out you'll love it check me out
on the road got upcoming dates all right
Tampa Florida coming you know who's
gonna be with me in Tampa Florida Steve
Simone Steve Simone's coming with me
Tampa August 18th and 19th I'll be there
September 1st and 2nd Springfield
Missouri September 15th and 16th Tulsa
Oklahoma that's the biz you guys know
what we're doing over here I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers ladies and gentlemen I am
very excited to have this guest on today
first time here on the Honeydew ladies
and gentlemen welcome Kirk Fox welcome
to the Honeydew Kirk Fox
I'm just watching I'm just just watching
you bring it in it was quite exciting
did you you feel you want to sit up on
that mic now I can you want me even
closer than that how's this is that
better yeah there you go already telling
me what to do yeah okay how's that
that's good now I feel cramped now I
gotta leave get comfortable Kirk Fox
well I was here oh yeah but you got to
be comfortable where people can hear you
I don't know I don't know if they need
to hear me they can get a feel uh Kirk
Fox it's a pleasure to ask you one
question since you said we're here for
an hour now I noticed you were looking
at that camera should I be looking at
this one you right here if you want to
look direct this is our wide right here
here on TV you know how it's worse I I
really don't know how the cameras are
wide okay that's mine so I will avoid
yours
I mean and that's me if I need it that's
you if you need to look at it you'll
edit this to make you look great being
live switched as we speak right now oh
see I didn't know that okay so right now
the world is seeing this no not it's not
airing live just Kirsten is switching it
actively while we're doing this so it
doesn't have to be done in
post-production okay so that's exciting
you with me well so I'm I'm slowly
working into it I feel you come in hard
and fast I remember that and uh you know
it's just not who I am I'm still trying
to find my footing in this little room I
see the mouth the Honeydew right okay do
I have a backdrop yeah you have a
backdrop that's a shot of me when I was
out in Nebraska with Tom where I don't
even want to look at it it's one of the
dates I did that you didn't do
we did the Chicago Arena together we'll
always have that in suits the only time
I ever wore a suit on stage with you me
too I didn't like it I didn't mind it
but I'm not gonna choose suits uh you
know we need more restrictions this show
has a lot to do with trauma I believe oh
uh all about drama when I put on a suit
I I'm not happy in the suit I feel
a little choked like a boa constrictor I
had a TV show Once where I had to wear a
suit every day and uh there was no
Comfort there was no happiness so can we
talk about that a little bit we can talk
about anything you want I love that
about you but before we do please feel
free to plug and you don't do this so
plug and promote everything tell people
where can they find you uh on TV you've
got two shows correct I do have two
shows they can also find me here uh on
honeydew I believe in July uh July 17th
I've heard okay so uh I'll plug that
date uh July 17th you can see me on
honeydew right there yeah there's a cup
of coffee but nothing in it but he'd
like me to take that so that uh you know
the merch is out there but uh I'm on
reservation dogs which is on uh Hulu but
it'll be on FX
July 26th they start showing uh it does
feel like an fx show I watch well it is
it's FX on Hulu but now it's gonna
actually be on FX so that's exciting for
me it's like I have a another TV show we
just wrapped the third season uh that's
where I got this haircut yeah I love it
uh it's a mohawk I believe so and I like
it
I've always wanted one but I was gonna
wait till someone paid me I still say
you got paid to wear this hair so it
looks good on you you'll find that out
in the next hour I don't like to spend
money I'm frightened
so that's that's trauma I don't want to
spend money I don't have any and I'm
looking forward to one day uh living on
the street
so that's interesting
see I know you and I still don't know if
that part's true and I believe
definitely I believe it absolutely could
be I'm a minimalist uh one day I dream
of just being by myself in a one-bedroom
apartment on a beach somewhere I do have
a family right now yeah I'd be okay
walking away
and that's rare
they know they know I'm looking not that
rare people walk away from their
families all the time well I told I told
you out front and marriage is a bit of
trauma and you say are you allowed to
say that
oh man I said I don't want to cause you
any problems but what could be the
problem if if you're honest in life how
could that be a problem you tell me I
I'm just telling you you're the one that
said you didn't want to cause any
problems yeah for you I don't who cares
so all right let's go to the beginning
do what you got where are you from I'm
from San Diego California is where it
started and do you have siblings uh I'm
the youngest of five five wow okay
according to my father I was the last
drip from a leaky faucet he literally
said that to you I'm not making it up
everything you hear today will be honest
whether you want to believe it or not
that's your problem was he a humorous
man or was he was that meant to be jokey
or was that meant to be like you didn't
have a good relationship and you were an
accident you know oh I'm sure it was
with it a twinkle in his eye but I mean
did you have a good relationship I've
had the greatest life ever that's why
you know let's talk about trauma well I
I don't really have any okay and even if
there has been it's all how you react to
uh a traumatic experience I ride the
middle all right that's a great list
that's a great album title right there
I'm not swayed by Praise or blame so if
someone dies I give them a hug and say
thanks all right tell me about your mom
did you have a good relationship with
Mom yes and did your parents have a good
relationship are they together so you
you're a product of five children and uh
your parents were married they were
married all right are they still with us
uh they're not they're not they've made
their exit who went first uh I'd have to
check the paperwork but I believe my dad
left before my mother how were you when
your dad died
I'm not good with age
it was in 2020 he was 86. so I don't
think I said how old were you when
you're done you can't subtract three
[__] years no
oh no I'm sorry 20 uh you said 20 20. no
that wasn't it he died in uh
2010. all right so 13 years ago your dad
passes oh sorry see I'm not good I think
it was in 2000. all right so that's
quite a while now yeah it's 23 years yes
that's fair enough yes so that's that's
kind of when he made his action what did
he pass from uh
it was some sort of cancer but he didn't
want to know he didn't go to the
hospital he just let nature take its
course is that I feel like that's
exactly how you would probably handle
that if I had four minutes to live
take me in two
if someone said if
if I could get all I needed to do
done
in two minutes all my goodbyes all my
thank yous
so that's it and I what oh god dude I
live my life where where does this come
from why why it doesn't just start that
way well who who taught you this clearly
it came from I would say my father not
your mom your dad I would say more of my
dad
he would say get out of bed stand on
your head take a deep breath and say
love
he'd say isn't it wonderful and we'd say
what and he'd say when we as Earth
planet Travelers become aware of our
relativity with the great universal life
force that's how I started every day as
a child as a child I try and carry it in
life do you do that with your son you
have a son right I think a daughter but
I'm not going to label her I think
that's up to her to decide but do you
think that's labeling just to tell
someone how to get up in the morning no
if she's a son it's oh I seriously it's
a daughter her name is Addison she just
turned five it's a great name
and I like being a dad yeah why what do
you like about being a dad it's just
nice to have someone
truly need you
I like when she looks up at me and says
Daddy
and I was just in La Jolla yesterday
and uh for two days it was her first
little vacation
and it was we stayed at the La Jolla
Beach and Tennis Club and at one point
she just took off running down the beach
and I started chasing her
for a long ways and it was It was kind
of Nightfall
and just running after her at full speed
was the best feeling I've ever had
in my life Wow
without without question and a lot of it
came back to uh
my dad was a house painter by trade and
he was painting a house down in La Jolla
and right there at La Jolla Shores
in the late 40s I think and they had a
little dog named Bruce
that he came out to California with on a
1947 Indian Chief motorcycle and Bruce
was on the gas tank wearing goggles and
whenever Bruce looked back my dad knew
Bruce needed to to take a pee what a
relationship and then my dad would kick
over the engine and the dog would come
wherever he was but my dad was painting
a house in La Jolla with this dog and
the dog suddenly took off down the
ladder
and started running down La Jolla Shores
right where I was chasing my daughter
and the dog ran for almost a almost a
mile maybe a half a mile
down toward Scripps and black speech
around the rocks and my dad finally
caught up to this dog and the dog was
barking at a woman
and my dad picked up the dog
looked at the woman and said one day
you'll be my wife
and that was my mom get Is that real
what did I tell you did tell me I said
if I was baby if I'm talking it's real I
didn't drive how your parents met I
didn't drive all the way to Santa Monica
to not be real I appreciate it so
Bruce that dog picked out Bruce chose
your mom yes for your dad and my mom was
actually engaged at the time to someone
over in Pearl Harbor okay the guy's name
was Robert Bruce Willis nah yes and my
mom went to Bobby Bruce Willis my mom
went to Hawaii
and decided to see which one she liked
most and then she came back and married
my dad
so when I was chasing Addison the other
night
along the beach
it was just like my dad was chasing
Bruce
or running to your mom well following
Bruce or running toward my mom but
whatever happened that night
on La Jolla Shores
80 years ago whenever that was
happen you know I was here because of my
dad and Addison was here because and all
right on that beach I mean it really
goes back to Bruce you're here because
of Bruce too it makes pretty wild little
Australian jumper
and then my dad married my mom
and moved in with her
and her mother in the same house that my
mom grew up in
and I married my wife
and moved into her house with her mother
is that right their child that's your
wife's childhood home yeah and her dad's
which was same as my mom's so I'm
mirroring my dad you really are and then
we squeezed out
her mom my wife's mom so now it's all
ours
[Laughter]
you stood me that much
but but that's that's who I am so where
does this come from I think my dad a
handyman in San Diego
but always very Zen like that always
very just
he was just floating as I am did just
enough
running down the beach is the greatest
moment of your life are you
um are you present in that while it's
happening or is that something you
realize in every moment you're able to
be there I'm where are you thinking
about your dad and mom and everything
during that run oh of course of what you
just told me it was it was a feeling of
oh because I knew I was at La Jolla
Shores where and I tell that story
so it was exciting
and was um when your dad passed were you
how was your mom with that
smooth because it's she was she was the
same way of course uh my dad died and
when he got that cancer he was supposed
to go quick
but he hung in there for another two
years
toward the end I said dad why why why
are you still here
supposed to have been gone a couple
years and he says I want to see your mom
so bad every morning
I just keep waking up Jesus Christ so
they had a they had a good little love
affair
I think I mean they slept separately
which makes sense no one really wants to
be locked into a a bed with a woman for
more than 20 minutes
so that's you know I mean I I share a
bed with my wife and I'm happier
when I don't have to are you
well of course why well you say of
course you say it like everyone feels
better I think every man would rather
sleep alone
no one wants to have to share a bed
are you a man I'm a man do you sleep
better alone no oh you need to be held
and cuddled I don't need to be held and
cuddle but I like to do the holding and
cuddling but yeah
yeah that's awesome big spoon me I love
that I'm not too [__] proud to be big
spoon well good I I like or or if it's
just you and me laying in there in the
bed as long as we're touching feet you
know what I'm saying I just don't like
it I just don't like to be touched it's
a little touch I can I sense that
I say I'm like sandpaper you know if I
if I bump you once it's gonna hurt but
if I just keep bumping you you'll be
smoother for the ride
that's
what you're all about I think so
but we're just down in La Jolla yeah at
the beach and Tennis Club and we had two
beds
and it was nice yeah my wife slept with
Addison and you got this and I had my
own bed right it's like as close as
having your own room
look I can appreciate that because I'm
one of three did you share a room
growing up too with more than no you had
your own room five kids by the time I
came around they were older yeah there
was a big gap I guess so
he always had the [__] I think at one
point I even shared a room with my dad
you know it's a real old house so there
was a big there was a big room once and
he was over in one corner and I was kind
of in the other corner
and so I think I I remember kind of
sharing a room with my dad what would
you say the best advice your dad gave
you was
or or at least maybe it wasn't a vice
but best thing he taught you
uh dulcet tones
kindness
Forge your tongue on the Anvil of Truth
that was one of his say he would say
those things yes
uh well the great thing was about my dad
uh
when he when he was 60 he was trudging
in the deep sand of Mission Beach
he liked to uh trudge in the sand
with a bamboo stick they called him
bamboo Ben
did where uh knit had you could just see
his eyes and he'd go down there every
every morning
he'd get up at sunrise and he'd look up
at the Moon good morning
this is [__]
how many times
I can't help people out there with me
right like I don't know right I'm with
you I don't know no they know it's they
sense truth you're the one that's
skeptical I have a little skeptical for
sure but you know every morning he'd
look up and say good morning morning you
know how are things up around the Moon
High Venus
and then he would drive down to Mission
Beach
and he would trudge in the deep sand and
one day he was trudging and
his heart stopped on his feet he
shortness of breath and he knew it was
the end
and he took a deep breath
and with his last breath he said
Raya
and his heart started beating
and he he trudged on
and for the next 20 years
he would trudge every day and everyone
would see bamboo Ben and they'd give him
Mariah
and always open fingers
what's that mean I'm going to tell you
okay
and everyone that saw him greeted him
with a rousing Raya and he'd even have
people trudging with him with bamboo Ben
and kind of toward the end I said you
know
what's Raya
and he says it's air backwards
it's the first thing we take in when
we're born and it's the last thing we
let go of when we die
he didn't know where it came from
shall I give Ariah often wherever I am
Ryan it's just love it's just did you
ever go trudge with yeah I trudged with
him once
and found a watch in the sand
so I never trudged again because I knew
I couldn't top that
but uh
and I still have and it was about
topping the watch for you but I you know
after he died I I went back I've gone
back and trudged in the same spot
whenever I'm down there and
little Addison does the Raya
right
you know so that I like I like being a
dad
we tolerate the wife and embrace the
child
I think that's I think that's what it's
about I didn't want to be a dad I
thought I'd gotten through life I didn't
want to be a husband
so so why why the shift [__] up [__]
up so it's nice I slipped what do you
mean I slipped you don't slip get
married
you can slip having a kid yeah I kind of
slipped how probably shouldn't have why
do you say that
because I don't think I'm built for
marriage
well you said you didn't want to be a
dad those are two different I didn't
want to be anything I like my life all
right let's talk about husband first
before okay why um why do you feel you
slipped why did you not want to be
because I I don't want to do anything I
just want to golf and play tennis and
call my own shots and not have to be
anywhere
but I think I say that's the DNA but
clearly not in you because you seem to
enjoy it but I like to I love it yeah
what about your dad had five kids did he
not really enjoy it probably not you
don't think so no why would you keep
having well he liked the kids that's
what I'm saying but I said I say I like
being a dad now but I never wanted it
until I had the child it's just
interesting to me that you're
the son of a man who said I I'm here
because every day I wake up and I still
want to see your mom yeah and then he
has such a good line maybe so has five
kids yeah so it just seems to me that he
did really whether they slept in
separate beds or not that's how how a
marriage works for two peoples their
business exactly and as long as it works
and they both are with it then [__]
everybody else but it seems like they
made their marriage work and that he was
happy enough that he didn't want to let
that go
um and then also had five kids so what
you seem to wanted to go the other way
with that of course but why you say of
course because that's just who I am I
guess just why I like that from the
beginning you always felt like that you
did you always always like being there
longing to be a dad or no you're
probably an uncle are you not a bunch I
think so
I
think they have some children does that
make me an uncle
I don't I don't think much about that
are you not involved in their nieces and
nephews I don't even know why I'm asking
that you don't even know if you have
I'm
always
thoughts
I always send good thoughts to everybody
so where does I probably could be a
better uncle will we throw a beer or a
better brother or better Dad husband
comedian partner what we all could be
better everything we do you can't be I
used to go to San Diego a lot for what
for my mom when she was alive but when
she was gone I didn't go back much
when did she how old was she when she
passed 83. wow all right they got up
there
and I was in I was in Edinburgh
a festival at the festival doing comedy
when she when she died
was that unexpected I kind of I sent
something your dad passed from cancer so
you know that yeah but I kind of for
some reason I felt something was in the
air
I just what did she pass from well
this is what's interesting
they think a stroke
but she was listening to a Padre game
she loved listening to Padre games
and this one went into Extra Innings
so she was up very late
because uh Trevor Hoffman couldn't close
all right and
real late she went out to turn off the
radio
and she fell and hit her head
oh
but they don't they they can't be sure
if she had
died and then fell and hit the head
but I blame
I think if he had closed
she would have been up so late I mean
the game went like 18 Innings so she
wasn't in her right mind
when she
when she tripped so that was that was an
80. so is that that was 2007 in Scotland
when you find us out yeah and that's not
are you how do you receive that call
do you cry no
no have you ever
you ever wept over the loss of your
mother or father no never no but
sometimes you're an emotional man I feel
like you are you're big I thought you
say you're a Buddhist so but do
Buddhists need to cry or just feel no I
didn't say you need it and I'm not
really a Buddhist I just kindness is my
Lane
so I just believe in love
so is that a Buddhist or just someone
who cares there's never been a a song or
a moment with your child where you
wished grandma or nothing that brought
you to no there's tears of joy when I'm
with the with Addison sometimes for some
reason ice skating
I'll cry a little when someone Falls and
I I don't know what that is I think it's
just that they've worked so hard and
then to slip so certain things like that
or when there's a stadium cheering and
when everyone's together I I feel uh a
tear okay so I can feel I know you can
feel
I know you can feel but if I have to on
film I I think I could
I can find tears
so
I miss my mom and dad but I feel they're
always with me and they had a good run
what do you miss about them uh I hear my
dad's voice come out of you often I'll
say things and I'll be like Ah that's
that's my dad
he had a real dry sense of humor
but I I think my dad and I are the same
Cut From the Same Cloth
he was he was interesting he was running
the he went to Okinawa did he but he was
running the crap games on the ship
throwing the Dyson
they found out
and they demoted him
they made him a potato peeler
but they let him keep doing the crap
games for morale
did they really
but most of the people on the ship
died
but he lived because he stayed on the
ship peeling potatoes
so that crap game saved his life saved
his life and he made damn good hash
browns
listen I used to go to my friends and
sleep over and I would always ask is
your dad in the military and they're
like yeah I'm like is he making
breakfast like yup and I'm like [__]
yeah it's like military dads kill
breakfast men they're so good at
breakfast used to be my thing man like
your dad was like my dad would buy
things at garage sales and he had a
a big a big machine that
you could put a whole head of lettuce in
there
a shred or whatever it is maybe it was a
paper shredder but he was just he put
the lettuce in there
and he would just make big Vats of [__]
like so he still had that Army mentality
so rice and beans he could live on
there's no quick fix for anxiety and
depression it's not finding a new
therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more and regular
meditation or a better diet sometimes
you just need something to unlock your
brain a new way of thinking about and
seeing the world and maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy for mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health at home ketamine therapy
mind Bloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy having safely helped
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in a study of over 1 200
mind Bloom clients 89 report
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering my listeners
a hundred dollars off your first six
session program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and use promo
code honeydew take the first step and
break free from your anxiety and
depression with mind bloom mindbloom.com
honeydew and use promo code honeydew now
let's get back to the do
and what about your mom was she artistic
what was she what was she like what did
she do uh she raised five kids she was
an artist she liked drawing but you know
once the kids start coming she's raising
five kids fives never never worked
never worked
so what made you want to go the other
way you feel like you're just wired that
way so all right well I have a child I'm
not married why did you go if you really
didn't want to be a husband why did you
get married uh part of me thinks I
stayed in too long I can't What in in
the relationship with her I took her 20s
from her she wanted to get married
then you did not at the time I still
have trouble with it how long were you
together before you said yes to marriage
well I met her when she was 23 okay
and it wasn't supposed to go this long
that's for sure
it was uh
I was an old man when I met her she
looked great she's beautiful
what's a CPA had a job I like that
she's quit the job which is
tricky I liked it when she went to work
I don't like the fact that I have to
make money now
I don't want to have to work I don't
want to have to do anything but I kind
of have to now but I started working
more when I had the child
I realized that I have to work now
so the minute I had a baby I've my
career is I've started working
they say with babies comes money I don't
know if you've ever heard that one I
have maybe I've heard it I just can't
hear because of my tinnitus yeah you
have tinnitus which we're going to get
to but I don't know if you'll have time
well I don't either but I want to keep
staying in this Lane right now because
this is really interesting to me okay so
you feel
so you're saying that you felt obligated
because you took her 20s and she'd
wanted to get married so you proposed
did you propose I kind of had to okay
but you did it I did okay she didn't you
did okay and Kevin Nealon was the
officiant he married us so I looked at
it as a party
and why do you say I kind of had to why
all the time you said propose no it was
just it was just hurry before you got
pregnant yeah okay
so there's no explaining it you're not
here I know I'm understanding so it's
not like you got but I still don't I
still don't understand what don't you
understand how it happened what do you
mean you were there was I yeah see
that's the that's the question
if I really was
if I really was there I don't think it
would have happened
so clearly I was not in my right mind
but isn't that maybe true but but it did
happen
I mean she's a great mother and
she's awesome and she does and she and
she does everything and
I'm just trying I mean if it wasn't for
her this kid would be eating out of a
paper bag and you know living in a box
all right so how long are you married
before you guys decide to have a child
I know you're not good with years but
are we talking years couple years pretty
quickly we got married in 2017.
and Addison was born in 2018. oh so
pretty quickly you got pregnant
I think the first attempt wow
my sperm were angry I guess yeah and you
were older too you said so that's that's
well done nothing closed
so she wanted to be a wife and a mom I
guess
it would appear so and you wanted to be
nothing you didn't want right you wanted
to be nothing but at the time now you
are a husband
are you embracing it or are you I'm
embraced nothing nothing
okay so when you get pregnant are you
now excited to be a dad I'm I'd like to
be a father okay so you're now so I'm
excited okay to be a dad right
and I realized I better be oh good
because she's I better be excited about
this yeah yeah you better be yeah
there's a woman pregnant and miserable
and there's a human in that belly that
needs you to be excited I guess so yeah
whether it's mine or not
did you were you concerned about that
well I think we're always hoping it's
not yeah I listen to your 100 I mean
wait no I had a day we're hoping it's
not I'll wait I I even heard that did
you miss him
I thought you said overall I had a
daytime talk show and every guy that
yeah found out he wasn't a dad sure
danced really
so let's talk about that for a second so
you actually did an episode of The Crab
Feast years ago with with Jay and I yeah
and you might have been the first there
were only a handful of episodes that
never aired for various reasons you
might have been the first and you were
in a dark place well that my tinnitus I
I had just gotten tinnitus oh you just
got it around that time yes so I
couldn't hear right so tonight is for
people who don't know is it it's a
constant ringing is high-pitched
squealing in your ear all day 24 7 at
what decibel level are you hearing that
is it a small quiet but steady or is it
loud and there's a thing called
habituation where the brain realizes
it's not a threat
you can survive with tinnitus but about
95 of the soldiers that kill themselves
have tinnitus
it's a killer I I couldn't imagine I've
said I've had my ear ring for like a
minute before so when I did yours I was
in the the middle of uh
that show that show and tinnitus had
just kicked in I think this was 2013 it
was a while ago 2013 because that's when
I got tinnitus
so when I went to do that podcast I I
felt I was a little testy
and I said you know we'll we'll do
something a little later when maybe I
also remember you telling me too you
were watching a lot of people find out
that this kid either is or isn't theirs
and and there's a lot of that going on I
was in the darkness I was in the middle
of a lot of fighting yeah
so I I think it was you're seeing the
worst of people on a daily basis I just
saw a lot of ugliness fighting yeah
and I think it it was
washing over me daily and I think when I
came to you guys it had been a probably
a lot of fighting and then I rushed over
there and I don't even remember why I
wasn't
I don't know why I didn't I don't know
why I called Jay and said you know let's
just shelve that one but I think it was
because I you felt a certain way because
to us I know you to us you were not I
know you hey you you know you better
than anybody yeah but but it's it's
always
even though I'm coming from my heart it
always comes off a little combative like
a lot of people can't get a read on how
to do a podcast with me they think I'm
not happy but I'm happy
I'm happy to to engage in honest
conversation and people can't really get
a feel for is he is he happy is he
unhappy is that [__] are you happy
yes
so you're able to find happiness even
though you're well so then are you
unhappy in your marriage no I'm fine
with it I I'm always does your wife know
you have these feelings that you're
sharing with us about marriage well of
course I think she knows that it's a
tricky ride for me
but that doesn't mean that I'm not
excited to have a great woman taking
care of me and she feeds me and keeps me
in clothing and picks out an outfit I've
just surrendered I'm just a leaf and
wherever the current takes me I mean
she's smarter than me
she's she does it all she gets the kid
in school the kid will start Brentwood
the kid's five this kid wouldn't
wouldn't have made it to one if it was
just me
so I know how lucky I am to have a woman
that put that puts up with me
I'm not a fun ride
but she's okay with it we gotta like
something about being married so what is
it I I don't nothing I I don't think
there's much about it I I would have
been happier just being with her but not
married
I don't like the paperwork okay
okay I mean look I I do think the paper
Works bad for business yeah it is bad
for business I mean marriage was created
thousands of years ago to unite families
and so I'm pretty sure that the church
can keep an eye on people and
it's a party women like the party but
then they don't think about it after I
mean it was sure a big deal
I feel like I feel like if there was an
adult prom a lot of weddings wouldn't
happen I could have figured out a better
way to you know spend 100 Grand a
hundred thousand probably when you add
it all up Bel Air Bay Club and cakes and
it gets steep yeah dude that's a talks
I've worn once since [__] why didn't I
remember it yeah exactly see I don't
make smart moves
she she kind of nudged me to buy and I
surrendered so then you you like maybe
there's regret maybe I regret that I
haven't been stronger and in my better
boundaries yeah for yourself yeah I'm
bad at boundaries maybe I you seem like
you all almost don't have any I just
yeah
I'm I I wish for death
that's a terrible thing is it yeah who
knows yeah I welcome it it could be
awesome
you know maybe my dad was miserable
um
hold on
I'm writing at that well I wish for Dad
yeah write that down dude
um
what do you think your good best at as a
father because you will like being a dad
so what are your strengths
Danger
before it
before it arrives seen it before she
bumps her head
it's uh she's a magic a magic child you
know she had some suffering
out of the gate
some some stuff that should probably not
even really aware of but so I'm I'm
extra protective of this of this child
she was born with something called
amniotic band syndrome an amniotic band
amniotic band what is that it's one in a
million is that right it's when there's
a little tear
in the in the womb in the amniotic sac
and constriction bands
swim around
and they usually kill a baby they every
time you see a child without a limb
they've had constriction bands but you
can usually see it it usually Tangles
around the child and they can see it and
they will terminate
but we didn't see it
it just looked like she was making a
fist
so when she was born we noticed that
a constriction ban had wrapped around
those four fingers
so we had to have them opened up so she
surgically cut open she had a lot of
surgeries wow and also a toe so sorry is
it almost like a web so to speak and
then they just had to go in and make
them individual they're yeah but it all
forms together like band a band had
wrapped around there
while she was forming I didn't even know
that could happen one in a million very
rare
so she's had a lot of surgeries and you
would do one side at a time
and these these four fingers are a
little short
no Nails on them
but she doesn't care and then you went
deep this way a little but she's strong
and fast and then on her left foot there
there was some damage to her toe so we
had to make a big toe he had to cut
there but nothing slows her down she's
the fastest in the class the strongest
not even uh
not even a concern about that and that
was because I wasn't
concerned because I'm all love you know
Jaron little tough it was a little tough
as a woman they might think she had
something to do with it but it's just a
fluke it's just a rare So with this
child I'm always
I'm always seeing I I never wanted to
have to suffer you know and she bumps
her head I feel bad and but she's fast
and strong and does it never even comes
up in conversation is she gonna be an
athlete I mean you you this isn't a lot
of something a lot of people don't know
is how you were great at tennis I'm one
of the greatest athletes in the world
you ain't called and the great thing is
is you know my whole thing when I when
she was pregnant I was like Hey as long
as she's got ten fingers and 10 toes
and healthy I'll be fine
and she didn't she was it was close
misted by you know a couple fingers
but but they're all they're all they're
all there they're all there they're all
there
but she's the best
so and she's kind and tell me about
tennis
um
how well we don't play tennis yet I'd
like her to play tennis your tennis
career how do you get involved in tennis
and how far did you go with it well I
didn't go as far as I should have why
uh because you didn't want to do the
work and stuff probably a little lazy at
heart didn't couldn't commit to a one or
a two-handed backhand
but I was a great tennis player we we
paid for my tennis lessons with loaves
of bread my mom cooked bread every
Sunday
and then we took a loaf of bread down to
Pacific Beach Recreation Center there
was a guy there named Dave Rath
not the manager I was going to say is
that but uh we gave him a loaf of bread
on Sundays and if there was an opening
during the week he'd give me a tennis
lesson but I spent the rest of time just
hitting against the wall
I just like being alone is that right
solitary time doing that and just
hitting against the wall how good you
get did you go to college for it yeah I
played at UCSD you did
and I played on the tour a little but
were you ever ranked uh sure I was
always right your highest ranking ever
not not high enough to even top hundred
no no
I mean you cracked the top hundred
that's still pretty incredible it's
amazing it's amazing isn't it like those
people are really good they're good so
where were you oh I could have been the
top hundred if I could commit
ment like right now you knew you had the
ability of course was it a little lazy
chasing girls nothing that's a surprise
to any athlete who has it all and
doesn't capitalize I'm better now than I
I was then but I physically can't carry
the frame
I now have the the backhand that I wish
I'd had it
10. of course
I
I wish I wish I'd known then what I know
now
got that nice strong one-handed backhand
but when I was growing up it was kind of
in between but now it's heavy and but I
just
I could probably take a few games off
anyone in the world but couldn't win a
set
I'm an old man tired fastest serve
well 140 at some point I had to buy it I
had a big serve but then if it came back
I was [__]
I was [__] if it came back
I just caught it and said all right I
mean I was 6'5 and I was a bass liner
so that's trauma I know your show's
trauma-based right is that yeah so much
my trauma my trauma comes from not
committing to a one-handed backhand at
10 years old also but you don't seem
like you want to commit to anything I
I'm just except for being a father which
is great you got to find something
I'm on the fence about that also well if
I'm able to walk away that's not being
too committed
well you are able to walk away well I
haven't right
I don't that's where I've always told
Jared and I said you know when I'm out
of money
I'm leaving
so I'm I'm close
this strike might push me down the
street
but she's great you know jaren's great
she's beautiful smart has the house I'm
married for land oh yeah that's old
school right there I'm old-fashioned
do you close with any of your siblings
not not really no I have a brother that
what's the closest age gap for you
you're the youngest I think 10. oh wow
with your 10 years they were all a year
apart and then I slid into the picture
yeah
but I think I get everything kind of
from my dad
I mean he you'll like this he had a
uh a Volkswagen I think maybe a Jetta or
something or maybe as a Honda Accord
whatever it was he took the passenger
seat out
and put a little table
in there
so that he could cut up cheese and
apples when he drove
and if someone if someone was with him
we'd have to sit in the back
and he never wanted to go
through a drive-through
he felt he had him in the car he felt he
wasn't driving he had it in the card but
that's that's where I came from he
painted you know garage floors in La
Jolla that was his gig for a while
because he he spilled a can of paint
once
in a garage
and instead of cleaning it up he just
painted the whole floor and they loved
it so he realized he was on that's a big
thing now too now it's like this poly
[__] they're putting down they probably
started it yeah but I I like the fact
that he took the passenger seat out
and so did Ted Bundy
for the same reason well I don't know if
it was pretty [__] mean people it
wasn't to put a table in there yeah Ted
Bundy took out the passenger seat so no
one could see the
the victim when he was driving but he
didn't have a passenger seat in his
Volkswagen either
shove my dad
different dude yeah but did you know his
parents at all no you don't know where
that comes from have you ever met anyone
like your father
no no me
I'm very I think I think I'm him yeah
I think I'm him
he's German I I my whole life I thought
I was Black Irish
I like ganis all my friends are Irish I
and I even toward the end of my mom's
life I said what part of Ireland
where are we from she says we have no
Irish and I'm like really my whole life
I've been rooting for a lot I'm like
where's Dad from me she's like he's all
German
it's all German and we're Scandinavian
so
have you done the 23andMe or anything no
but Jaron was 23 when I met her
I was 23 in me
so I've done it once you know
I miss her 20s
she's old now 35 I think old get the
[__] out of here I liked her in their
20s
23 was a good year I thought he was a
good year 23 and me
um how are we doing on time great I
don't just don't want a parking ticket
if you get one I'll pay
I'll pay more oh okay
um
don't cut that out I'm not cutting
anything out okay good
um why don't you have a close
relationship with your siblings what is
that about well I love them I I just
don't want to drive are they all local
are they insane San Diego is that local
I mean two hours that's a long almost
two and a half yeah you're right on a
weekend but still
I love them I just they don't come up do
they come to see you on shows whatever
you do La Jolla they don't come out uh
they did a cup once or twice okay but I
didn't I prefer they not you do why just
don't want to have to get them seats
make those phone calls make sure they're
seated
I'm a bad man I don't know if that's bad
I think it's bad can't make the effort
to make a phone call you know hey can
you give two seats to my brother
okay
now I have to call are they hear me like
hey why don't you come have lunch while
I'm in La Jolla then you don't have to
go to a show or nothing like that it
doesn't cross your mind oh it crosses it
does and then I cross it right off
it doesn't it doesn't stay crossed long
I mean I love them I I'm I love them I
just
don't seem to want to do much
this was effort
to come here but it's good for me it is
good for you to practice and you know
practice Yeah explain what you said
about practice practice talking in case
of an emergency like if there's an
apocalypse I want to be able to ask
someone for help or yeah help or Worse
food or I borrow a jacket all right so
let's entertain this for real now
um
your daughter's 18. is she I'm saying
she wants to go to college whatever
she's gonna do her thing
is this when you transition into hermit
full-time hermit are you gonna do you
think you'll stay married do you think
you'll be married the rest of your life
I'm sure I'll stay married forever
you're not gonna just go but you but all
on paper but I'm saying are you gonna go
live that hermit lifestyle you're
talking about maybe downstairs
maybe I'll go spend more time down in my
office
do you crave alone time yes you do
yeah why hey man
I just love it yeah I love bricks I like
being around bricks what do you mean I
just love bricks I love I collect uh
Rusty Bolts from the 1940s I pick up
every nail I see you pick up Nails yeah
and do what with them well get rid of
them so they don't cause flat tires okay
that's nice but why are you collecting
bolts just like the feel of rust
like the for real you like the feel of
rust sure well how do you know if a bolt
is from the 40s well yeah you can tell
I'm pretty good at seeing that if a
Bolt's been around for a long time and
where do you find but mostly look around
you see them on the ground
because I've already picked them up
but I I just you know I think I'd be
happier in the 1800s just on a horse and
a couple gunfights and a saloon
stake in a hooker and a steak for a
dollar and that's good business
that's that's your Vibe clearly yeah I
wear I'll wear this jacket every day
until it's gone
I'm a creature a habit I mean a lot of
us are creatures I've had well then a
lot of these questions you asked me you
already know the answer I don't you
answer them differently though okay but
you know you asked way differently you
ask me things but you shouldn't be too
shocked I'm blown away that I gotta oh
you'll like this story about your dad
pulling the seat out I love that I love
that it took you there
um what's out why are your does
everybody all right so let me pause for
a second gather myself your siblings the
four the four other ones are they close
to one another
for you guys all sort of your own
I think we're all kind of sort of made
your own little tribes and you keep to
yourselves so to speak but we love each
other you're not going down for a
birthday or anything like that I they
don't come up for your daughter's
birthday no they're not uncles and aunts
and presents I have a I have a sister
that
has reached out more and would like to
come visit but I seem to not entertain
that long why
who knows why I just
don't you ever think that even though
you're who you are in the way you are
that your daughter is who she is and the
way she is and that maybe we took uh we
took Addison to see her two aunts
I'm saying
cousins and stuff don't you think she'd
like to reach out to them I'm gonna have
to try
I'm gonna have to be better
I'm I'm aware that I need to be better
why are you aware of that because uh I
have a child now that
I would like to
make her not be like Dad
why because this isn't the way to exist
why though I thought you enjoyed the way
you are well it's good for me but it's
not going to cultivate Humanity
a guy who just wants to play with bolts
and Bricks
that's not
I wouldn't recommend this it's a it's a
tricky ride
it's a tricky ride you're trying to
figure out how to even
talk to me
well I'm not trying to figure out how to
talk to him well you're trying to figure
out into that brain a little more well
it's a I have a 186 IQ so it's pretty
hard to get in here
it's a it's a pretty strong IQ that is a
good IQ
so I'm a genius who's using it for all
the wrong reasons
I can make the world better but clearly
I'm not
well I don't know your daughter could
end up being president and do good
things you can do anything she wants but
then ultimately you have helped make the
world better oh that's a long game Kirk
Fox we're not going to be here to see
the end oh I know I could be gone in
four minutes
and take me into please dude that's so
good Addison will she makes the world a
better place what has she how she made
your world a better place well I now
love something besides chicken tacos
so that's it's fun to love
yeah
I never loved not like that
I don't think like anything yeah
yeah so when I hold this kid I I feel
something so it's nice to love does she
Point things out where you're just like
yeah wow she's like me she says hi to
every tree she says I love you to
everyone she sees I love you she's just
a bright light
she's kind and smart
she likes being alone too though does
she so
she's she's picking up on me
like when she took off running down the
beach if I didn't catch her I think she
would have been gone yeah like
she would have kept going
and it was funny because I was just
having a
a skewer of steak
from someone's barbecue
so the fact that I could have a free
skewer on the beach there [__] I forgot
I was married I forgot I was a dad
I had an IPA and a
steak and I was just in heaven and then
I looked around and the kid was gone I
was like oh [__] so I just started
running and sure enough I saw her little
pink outfit she had a 50 yards on me
eventually caught her
but it took a while and then we just
kept going and then I ran with her yeah
and like I said that was
that was the worst of times and then it
became the best of times
it went from where's my kid
is she gone did someone grab her to
there she is I'm gonna catch her
and she's running right along the water
yeah
and then and then it mirrored the the
circle of life
so bottom line
I'm better than I was good
I love my daughter
I'm married
ah
I wish I'd I wish I'd found my backhand
at 10. yeah and uh well so then let's
end it with this then because I first
guessed I told you before if you wanted
to find your backhand attend advice you
would give to your 16 year old self what
are you saying to Kirk Fox if you can go
back and give him some wisdom
um
take more chances
my whole life I've avoided Danger
and I would have told my 16 year old
self
get more scars
get more scars I like that so that's
what I would have
said to myself at 16.
and if I had done that it would have
been a different road I don't mind where
I'm at now it's fun to be a late bloomer
I'm uh
I'm a better actor
because of it because I've learned to
listen and be open and better comedian
trying to be seamless in life
maybe I would have told my 16 year old
to be seamless
to be the same way everywhere
I want to have this honest conversation
with you and we laugh and I pour some
truths out and I and I hear it and I
realize that it's probably not the
the lane that I
would recommend others live in but I
like that I'm better than I was
I like that I love my kid yeah but being
seamless means to be like this right hey
one second I'm gonna go on stage I'll be
right back and then I go on stage and
I'm the same guy as opposed to for many
years I'd go on stage and I'd be a
character what's up
and it never felt right again and I
maybe got more laughs
but I'm happier in between the jokes now
um I like that and the audience
can tell when you're in between jokes
that's why they laugh harder at a moment
in between a joke because they feel it's
just for them
Humanity in general is selfish they're
ego based
so if they're getting something before
anybody else or if they know if they're
hearing a joke everyone's heard it but
if there's a moment
on the fly in between a joke that's when
they laugh the hardest yeah and it's
also when I'm the the happiest because
that's a a truthful moment a lot of
jokes are seeds of truth that we water
with our imagination to make it work
but those moments in between
[Music]
there's nothing calculated about it
so that's what I would tell 16 year old
Kirk just always be kind always be
seamless
it's great and get more scars man thank
you for doing this hey man I think I did
well you did great I'm proud of you for
getting out oh man I see I'm not so bad
tell them where they can find you again
watch you all that stuff social media
whatever you want dates uh reservation
dogs great show FX on Hulu it's now on
FX and I'm on a show called jury duty
right now I gotta watch that you can
find that uh free it's on freebie Amazon
it's the biggest show in the world
and uh that's a fun ride that's a fun
ride there was a a real sweet guy that
made all the right decisions and I
played a grumpy old man so I played
myself he just showed up
I just said I was one of the I was one
of the jurors and I just sat in the
corner and didn't say too much
thank you for coming on I really
appreciate it as always ryansickler.com
Ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign